University of Toronto professor Jordan
Peterson has become a phenomenon that's
not an overstatement video is featuring
him online get millions of views his
book 12 rules for life and antidote to
chaos is one of the biggest maybe the
biggest bestseller ever written by a
Canadian author in that book Peterson
questions the left's rhetoric on gender
and maybe for that he's being targeted
for destruction
The Guardian calls him dangerous Vox
just published a massive and almost
unbelievably stupid piece accusing
Peterson of quote reactionary politics
that validate white straight and
cisgender men at the expense of everyone
else really mouth-breathing Lee stupid
but there you have it jordan peterson
joins us tonight professor thanks for
coming on so obviously a hurt dog barks
you've done something that have has made
people upset what do you think you've
said that the left finds so provocative
and upsetting well i pointed out quite
clearly why they're factually incorrect
and and ideologically possessed
possessed I mean is particularly on
issues like gender and the left radical
lefties insist that gender is a social
construct and that's just simply not
true so the scientific data on that are
absolutely crystal clear and no
reasonable scientist disagrees and so
they're all foaming at the mouth because
I'm pointing poking holes in their in
their cherished notions and I don't
think that people are completely
malleable because that means they can be
people can be made over in their
ideological image so they're not happy
about that so when they say your ideas
are dangerous what they're really saying
is your ideas are dangerous to them I
hope so
they're supposed to be dangerous to them
I make no bones about that I'm not a fan
of radical leftists look at what
happened in the 20th century with
radical leftist ideology what is your
job been like back in academia I mean
you you can't be one of many people who
has these views where you live and work
oh yeah well no no I think they're more
common than you think I mean my views on
gender for example in sex they're
they're shared widely among people in
the psychometric Personality community
anybody who studies personality and
who's a credible scientist knows full
well that the differences between men
and women and purse
they are to be attributed primarily to
biological factors it's not this isn't
contentious the only people it's
contentious around there are gender
ideologue sand they've already lost the
scientific battle and so they've taken
it to the legislative front to enforce
their views so they're really not
contentious viewpoints they're
mainstream science and they're are
criticized all the time for spouting
pseudoscience it's like it's not
pseudoscience it's mainstream science
and and all and and people who know the
literature aren't disputing this it's
been known since the least since the
1990s well then why are people whose
views are not rooted in science but
instead in emotion and superstition
dominating our public conversation and
punishing anyone who doesn't disagree
how did they get so much public I
actually think there's a technical
reason for that is that you know it's
obvious that things can go too far on
the right and they can go too far on the
left and it's kind of easy to put a box
around people who go too far on the
right you can just look at claims of
racial superiority right but it's not so
easy to put a box around people who go
too far on the left there's not a single
thing you can point to that they do that
has the same sort of red flag nature as
claims of racial superiority so it's
hard for people who are left-leaning say
and concerned with inequality and that
sort of thing to dissociate themselves
from those who have clearly gone too far
and the problem is we really don't know
where the red flags are on leftist
territory now for me it's equality of
outcome is a good you know so-called
equity that's a red flag but it doesn't
seem as immediately pathological as say
claims of racial superiority so it's
harder for people on the left to
dissociate themselves from the people
who would what would do everyone in
essentially so you drew the line at
pretending the biological sexes in real
I mean that's how you first became
famous because you said I'm not gonna
lie about science well it's a good place
for the rest of us to start well I think
it's a reasonable place I mean the the
Canadian government built a social
constructionist view of gender into the
law and that that's just incorrect I
mean the idea that biological sex gender
expression gender identity and sexual
preference have no relationship to one
another that they very independently
that there's there's almost nothing you
could claim that's more false than that
but now it's being written into the law
so it's just patently absurd and it's
it's actually a
a telling commentary on the state of
political discourse across the West that
that's something like that could even
happen
yeah but I think it's equality of
outcome that's the real pathological
desire now it's that's that's a bad one
all right I agree but I mean I guess the
good news is that taking a stand on
behalf of obvious truths there's a huge
audience for it in your living testament
to that thank you professor good to see
it you know good to see you too thanks a
lot Thanks
all right